welcome to this video and play nevermind
teammate of mine so I know that he's
only recently taking up the Sicilian so
let's see what what happens I am this he
wants to try to transpose to a French so
let's um let's play French mmm yeah the
idea of this is as far as I know to play
a quick Bishop d7 be five okay so basics
here still a three are not young okay
let's do that
I don't play the advanced french so not
quite sure yeah a six now looks a bit
like a loss of temple but I'm not sure
how awful that really is okay now is
closing it sometimes there's b3 and c4
and this is quite strong not sure this
is one of those positions I go for
another plan with H for Bishop h3 I know
that this is at least the plan that some
played that quite often
curious I mean the time spent yeah maybe
this was a position for be 3-yard I'm I
really don't know okay yeah at least now
it's difficult for black to ever play f6
or any F poor move faster the King side
is some is weakened and typically just
as I stayed this is difficult to play
black is playing it okay hmm yeah i mean
i don't really think that black an can
easily grab the porn maybe you should
just for for practical reasons but it is
certainly dangerous for Felina okay
rookie one that's night d3 maybe I had
this add this in mind anyway intending
95 and after the capture Queen takes I
really have a good device on which are
easy relatively easy moves and Queen
back and then Bishop g5 yeah but the way
out to eat to we have meth and then
Bishop g5 and pressurize the center
Bishop g5 first and rookie one is
basically winning the spawn I don't see
how he could defend it maybe castles
okay it can take yeah I can take them
because of the pin Bishop f2 des regev
to so the sum this does not look like
especially great not not at all
now he's got this pressure on f2 now
which is a problem how to defend this
rock t one rookie to look T to their
special of to check and that's not good
yeah maybe I need to have attacked e5
could claim any alternative yeah
probably not that's surprising a bit at
least hmm ok i don't i don't have
anything better
we should have to getting the poem back
check I hope that this is strong he has
a slightly exposed podium yeah but ok
this should be a draw rly he's got g67
as a reserve temple it's a bit risky to
exchange him for me
yeah that still should be a draw pretty
I have G form and now I can just maybe
it does not really matter
hmm but ma isn't this a bit tricky now
hmm each six is not winning out now
probably it's just just the draw
yeah it's just a drawing shocked nothing
that I can do about it
hmm King Air Force Q yeah yeah stalemate
no not had no choice this is the
important defense IAM with King fo other
than that it's a it's losing yeah it's
um it's a draw anyway he have briefly
thought I might have something but it's
um it's it's still a draw yeah it's very
important that black it it's not doing
this year tempo and then I'm getting the
pawns yeah yeah I don't know I thought
it would be dangerous the spawn sack but
he easily defended this really easily
and this is just the drone endgame not
much to do about it yeah so probably the
pawn sec wasn't good and here should do
something else yeah mm-hmm this move may
be attacking him and he can he can shut
the position down with chief with f5 but
of course this is all for weakening like
here here here and so on very close down
yeah this is this is risky ahem for
black pit probably okay okay I really
don't see how to improve him maybe there
should be three yeah this is a
possibility really yeah so that I can
exchange and then try to keep
this blockade intact later winning the
porn back maybe this could be an idea
probably not not anything brilliant but
this is maybe a bit more dangerous than
the than the other line would have
played okay thanks for watching